-I am a big fan of the show.
I'm so happy it's coming back.
I would imagine this was
a very exciting role to get,
yet you had some family members
who were not that excited
when you were first cast.
-Me grandad wasn't very happy.
Yeah, he's like, "Bloody hell,
you're not playing bloody Burke,
are you?"
He's from Nottingham,
which that probably doesn't make
much sense here.
But it's in the North
of England, or the middle
of England, yeah.
-And he called him a Burke?
-A Burke.
-Okay, gotcha.
Meaning?
-Meaning an idiot.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Light laughter ]
-Because my granddad thinks that
Prince Phillip is an idiot.
But he's not!
He's a very astute, clever,
charming, intelligent man,
I like to think.
But so is my granddad.
He's, you know.
-And you -- you actually met
Prince William?
-I met William and Harry, yes.
-And had -- had
the show been on yet?
-No.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I was -- I was presented
to William at the Polo.
-Oh, that's the most British
thing that anyone's ever said
on this show.
-Yes, I know.
But I was presented to William.
-That was like a hat trick --
presented,
Prince William, the polo.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm not really
very posh, either.
I mean, I talk posh
when I'm nervous.
-No, your -- your grandfather
says "Burke."
We know where you're from.
-Yeah, exactly.
And the lady next to me said,
"Oh, yeah, he's playing --"
And I thought, "Don't do it,
don't do it, don't do it,
don't do it."
"He's playing --"
"Oh, don't do it."
"He's playing Prince Phillip."
And I went, "Oh,
Christ, she's done it."
And all he did was,
he went, "Legend."
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
-I'm like, "What?"
And he went, "He's a legend."
And I went, "Yeah,
he is a legend."
-Oh, that's great.
It's very nice to hear
that from Prince William.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now this is an interesting time
for the show.
It's going to keep going,
but you will --
both you and Claire
are going to be recast.
-We've been moved on.
-Yeah, 'cause they're going
to get older actors
to play them older.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Are you -- it has not
been cast yet, right?
Is that correct?
-Well, I don't know.
-So, you maybe know.
-I maybe know.
I mean I don't know if I know.
I'm not meant to know,
but I maybe know.
-Okay, now, is part of you
though, "Oh, that's who
they think I'm going to look
like in ten years?"
-If it's the person
that it could be,
I was just totally flattered.
-Oh, great.
-How marvellous.
-Oh, that's exciting.
'Cause you --
This has happened once before.
We were talking backstage,
one of my favorite movies is
"In Bruges."
-Yes.
-You played --
There was a flashback scene
where you played
a young Ralph Fiennes.
-Yes, yes.
-Which is a fan --
I mean, that is -- you can't ask
for more than that.
-And it's Martin McDonagh,
and it's such a great film.
And Ralph is one of
my favorite actors.
I just think he's electric, so.
-So, is this on the level of --
Is this Ralph good, or is
this maybe a little lower?
Like, where are you at here?
-Well, you know --
Look, I don't want to
kind of speculate too much.
But yeah, no, he's brilliant.
-Okay, good.
-If it's the person
I think it might be.
And he's incredibly
handsome as well.
Which, you know --
-All right, good.
Well, fingers crossed for you.
I really hope.
-I have morphed into someone
far better looking than I.
-I want to ask about this,
because obviously when you
take on something like playing a
member of the the royal family,
there's going to be intense,
sort of, fan attention to it.
But you maybe did something that
has even more fan attention
when you played
the eleventh doctor...
-Yes.
-...on "Doctor Who."
-When I played Harry
in "In Bruges," yes.
-Yeah, exactly.
So, when you got that role
to play the doctor, had you --
did you understand that world
you were stepping into?
-Not really.
Nothing -- nothing can really
prepare you for the sort of
enormity of that part.
And funny enough, one of
the papers sort of found out
and then -- at the time,
I had a Brazilian girlfriend.
And one of the British
newspapers went up to
my granddad's house, again.
I'm just bringing my poor
granddad into it again.
And they knocked on his door and
they said, "Oh, you know,"
and they actually offered him
a huge amount of money,
and said,
"Who's his girlfriend?"
And he said, "I don't
bloody know, Carmen Miranda."
Who's a famous Brazilian singer.
-Yeah.
And slammed the door
in their face.
And I went, "Yes, Gramps.
Good lad."
[ Laughter ]
-But the fans, were they great?
Like, once you enter that world.
-Yes, I mean, at first
they hated me because David was
so popular and they were like,
"Don't break 'Doctor Who.'"
And everyone hated me
and I thought, "Oh, God,
I'm just going to die."
And it was an awful thing.
But then eventually, I hope,
that they've now accepted me.
But you know, the great thing
about that show is,
is that they love or
they hate their doctor.
So everyone has their doctor.
And for some people, I will be
their doctor and to some people,
David Tennant will be theirs,
and et cetera, et cetera.
-Well, that's a nice way
of looking at it.
You -- Again, we've heard a lot
about your grandfather
which I'm very happy about.
-Yeah.
He's a top boy.
-And so, seems like a salty guy.
You seem again, very kind,
very well put together.
Certainly, we see you
on that show.
Me?
-Yeah, very polite, but then --
-Thank you very much.
-True story that you were --
a fight? Did you get
in fights in schools?
-Oh, yes, I have had
a fight at school.
-Just one though?
-Well, yeah.
Well -- well, yeah.
One that was significant,
I suppose.
-Memorable?
-Yeah, you know.
Ish.
-Did you start it?
What happened?
-No, I didn't start it,
actually.
It was in history,
and that was the one subject
that I was in the top set for.
I'm more intelligent
than I look.
And you know,
we were debating a point,
and there was one
very clever lad, chap,
in school, who was demeaning me,
frankly, and my point of view.
So, then, you know,
I proceeded --
Anyway, I mean, you know --
I leapt over the desk and told
him I would shove his trumpet
up his ass.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause he was
the school trumpeter.
-Yeah.
-And he was a smug pillock.
[ Laughter ]
-That escalated so quickly.
-Yeah, and then there was
fisticuffs, and I got suspended
and I went home and I told
my dad and he laughed.
-Okay.
-And I thought I had him on side
and tnen I was very nonchalant
about it.
And then my dad was like,
"Oy, reign it in.
Sort it out,
don't get suspended."
-Well, I think if anything,
he should have given that speech
to his father, because obviously
that's where it all started.
-Yeah, yeah exactly.
-Well, hey, man, thanks so much
for being here.